[Music]
all right what's up guys today i am
making ceviche at Bart's house TIFF and
G are off doing the girls all-girls
podcast today and they're gonna miss out
on a pretty awesome USC fight which is
the reason why I'm at Bart's house today
it's like right now it's just me Bart
and Tyga but we're gonna have some
friends come over I asked Bart what he
was gonna be making for the potluck
thing that we're doing for the COC thing
and he's doing pokey so I thought oh
I'll go along with those seafood thing
and I'll try my hand at making ceviche
today I've never done ceviche before so
I'm kind of nervous because I don't know
when you're dealing with raw food that
isn't actually cooked with flames and
it's cooked with lime juice it kind of
makes me worried because I don't want to
be the one responsible for making people
sick I don't know if I'm gonna be any
good at it I've looked at a couple
different recipes online and for me I
don't particularly like following
specifics with recipes I like
cross-referencing like multiple of them
and getting the gist getting the idea of
how to make it and then making it on my
own and turning into my own thing so I
hope I interpret all the differential
because I've looked at I hope I
interpret it correctly and the
proportions are gonna be right and hoped
it's gonna taste good and yeah oh yeah
the UFC if I were watching into the bead
versus Poirier fight the last time you
we blogged anything UFC related I know
we don't ever actually follow UFC in
this vlog universe that we have with you
guys but the last time we did anything
yesyes related was the khabib and
McGregor fight and the beeps making this
comeback and we're gonna watch eat and
have a good ol time today
jeez shelling that took Oh time did not
anticipate how long that was gonna take
so I think Bart is now beating me you're
ahead of me now race yeah well I started
before you did so I was like I'm not
gonna everyone's arriving on the umberto
got your food already and stuff
pressures on all right so the fights
over everyone has left the building
it's just Barton texting me again and
this ceviche was they hit at the party
we got some leftovers I want to show you
guys what it looks like and why yeah I
never served the ceviche but it was a
hit though I'm not lying about being a
hit because when I was making and
everyone's coming in I was soaking up
the shrimp everyone's like what are you
making shrimp so I felt like oh yeah
this is gonna be a hit at the party but
I never got to serving it because if you
look closely the shrimp didn't cook all
the way it's like still kind of grain
like I said it was my first time making
ceviche and the authentic recipes that I
had looked up online they all referenced
the cooking times in the line to be
about an hour to two hours and a half
that was always in that time timeframe
so I was thinking oh I can marinate for
like an hour to two hours and a half and
like you know because you did some time
in the middle of the potluck but it
never cooked and now looking thinking
back at the recipes I was looking at and
like thinking about why this is still
raw very very raw I think it's because I
wasn't using like fresh fresh fresh
limes and juicing the lines myself
because I thought the the bottle the
bottle lime juice and maybe the acidity
in the bottle lime juice isn't as strong
as fresh lime juice which sounds like a
no-brainer now that I'm saying it out
loud so yeah
the total fail in terms of getting it to
cook we never ate the ceviche it was
only $30 of shrimp so not too bad of a
las I guess I don't know we'll see huh
I'm gonna eat it
a couple more hours just a couple more
hours TIFF and Gia should be on their
way back they're still they were still
they've been doing the podcast all day
today so if anything maybe the cooking
time for them to get back and then we
can have a ceviche dinner instead of
throwing out the shrimp so fingers
crossed fingers crossed I think this has
got to be my biggest fail in terms of
providing food at a potluck ever sigh I
mess up a lot of food sometimes for pot
Luck's but it's never been this bad
where I just never got to serving my
food ever kind of sad about that a
little bit but it's okay
it's my first time I was overly
ambitious it's all good
[Music]
I'm taking my teeth cut just ate a plate
of food but I'm down to check my brain
stops working
well you had a whole day of filming and
we had so many fun guests today but add
Cassie home we had pokey main and we had
mia khalifa and then we had a cop friend
of Gio's who has had experience being an
undercover and so we got to talk about
her experiences today so that was really
oh yeah her awesome with you yeah but I
knew I'm gonna try your ceviche you told
me about your ceviche mishaps yeah Bart
gave me a heads-up on what he thinks you
would say you and Gio would say you
should have cooked over a real alarm I
was like I know what you're gonna say I
know her best engines list not buy me
enough mm-hmm I swear I use real lines
lots of it you're missing so much like
all the other flavors you don't care for
the other flavors they bushes online
you'd be happy yeah baby it just feels
like it's cooked like in water like
boiled cooked not cooked in lime cooked
when I a ceviche with gel and all the
ones that she likes I'm
okay he's had this much another life
it's a lot it has to be cooking for a
certain amount of time to at least
overnight all the online recipes failed
me then because now I'm like reading
other recipes outside the three or four
that I found in my cross-reference yeah
some of them mention six hours yeah
let's do it
those are my favorite kind of life what
it kind of lands you see it's kind of
life for the keyline teas I don't know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
where we're standing right now in front
of our house yeah
now we actually have a like the skeleton
like the bones of the house we can
finally see because this whole time has
only been the foundation how do you feel
how do you feel so in two weeks or
exactly ten nine days from today we get
to go to design center and pick out the
floors and the cabinets and like the
countertops and everything and that's
gonna be a super like this the thing
I've been looking forward to the most
but just to see it like this now and
it's not just land it's pretty exciting
we paid money to hold this spot when we
paid that
money it was just dirt and and then now
over the course of a couple weeks we
I've seen them label cement there's
anything now and now they've erected it
now so it's like our neighbors still
it's not standing yet it last week was
like that but this is ours
yeah and then our other neighbor and the
funny thing - every time I come visit
the house I'm always wearing the wrong
shoes like dude I need to remember if I
plan to come all right what's up guys
just got dropped off to meet up with
Brandon Julia and we picked up some set
to fuel our journey and our journey now
is to go location scout for the JK
project so location scouting is a
process you do where you go to the to
the actual location that you're gonna
shoot at and you figure out like you
know the texture the look is it
something that I want and we shoot here
how loud are the neighbors how our
servers or you know outlets for lighting
you know like little logistical things
like that creative options of like which
side of this location of do we want to
shoot like things like that we're gonna
consider today we're gonna check out
three places and these three places are
pretty crucial actually for our script
and very big pivotal moments happen at
this location so super excited and once
we can check off this scouting we can
move on move into scheduling and
hopefully get everything on the way how
do you guys feel about producing you
guys are like I live and breathe it man
specifically laugh producing that's
that's specific so which is like which I
think it's pretty great because be tour
kind of sees the big picture he was like
me we can get this on my guy you got it
I'll get that for ya guy and that's a
perfect balance always in our meeting
like what about this thing now it's like
Oh totally overlooked bad and even
realize Julian thinks about the little
tiny things yeah that's awesome we work
we work in a very good or good pairing
yeah it's really really good it's honest
even fun producing this I think we've
all been itching to do something with a
narrative on a bigger scale you know
what's crazy is like we you know we did
skits for so long and we all got burned
out from doing the skits because the
skits if you guys said it no we would
only budget like maybe a hundred bucks
max in terms of what we would spend on
each skit so all the skits you've seen
in the past they were done on a
shoestring budget
and the only thing that we actually
spent money on was probably the gun food
thing which was I just remember gun food
I came around the time when gun food was
just being put together yeah and I just
remember that like compared to the skits
and I think I only did like one or two
skits with JK at the time and then we
went off to go I was like a hole in the
world just what they do on a daily like
my mind was so blown and after gun foo I
felt like everything kind of went down a
little bit the group of like just get a
special treat but this is kind of like a
blend of the two so we're not exactly
trying to spend too much on his projects
it's kind of like a proof of concept you
want to take this idea and submit it to
figure Studios and see if they think
there's any value in it and see if they
would want to fund like the rest of the
project so we're not trying to throw too
much in there but we're also not you
know limited to a hundred bucks yeah
so this is nice this is a nice like we
have a nice playing room here we go
location number one
[Music]
this is location one this is that movie
set clutter that like would take so much
money to like put together alright so
for our first location we're looking for
its a rundown lot for a character and
this character is like a paranoid like
weirdo kind of guy and we needed like a
rundown lot to have this character live
in it and to make it feel real and very
lived in for him this location seems to
be perfect for that it kind of checks
off we got like you know just junk and
and clutter and and random just
construction pieces laying around
perfecto
alright so we are now at location number
two we've been looking for that
like cuentas mexican rush from very
moment SOB and judging from the looks of
this place walls your yellow there
playing that faint like Latin music in
the background like that old timing a
lot of music entice a fan - it's like
the ceiling fan I don't know what it is
about silly man but it makes it look
like legit there's five in space
[Music]
like very timed piece yeah cuz now you
have that touchscreen yeah like you flip
it over to the customer and the cream
yeah let's do whatever they want but
this one all manual is very true yeah
see that's the thing about a location
scout you want to find places that look
like you're lived in and they have
history because I'm gonna go even when
it translates onto camera it feels real
oh man I wish I brought chip with me on
this location scout now she's gonna see
this footage she'd be like
[Music]
[Music]